Zelda maker may not be a thing just yet
but that isn't stopping the community
from creating Zelda inspired courses in
Super Mario maker 2 here are some of the
best we've played so far
Zelda switch puzzle dungeon by Danny ho9
is essentially its own unique Zelda
dungeon filled with intricate puzzles
based mostly on on/off switches this
course tests your skills and knowledge
of Mario's toolset there are also a lot
of key doors
what good Zelda dungeon doesn't have a
lot of key doors make it to the end and
you'll be treated with a nice musical
surprise the grey plateau by Garrett 64
is a fairly faithful recreation of the
grey plateau from breath of the wild you
start off inside the shrine of
resurrection and then you're free to
choose any direction to go next just
like the original game there are 4
shrines in total just like the grey
plateau we won't spoil the rest from
here beyond the grey plateau by raschi
ram 52 is technically a sequel to the
last course although they're made by two
different creators there are 5 shrines
in total but you only need four to
satisfy the clear condition you can do
the shrines in any order you wish both
this course and the last one shown use
ice blocks to mimic the sheikah energy
emanating from the shrines in breadth of
the wild and that's a nice touch The
Legend of Zelda Spirit Tracks in the
field theme is impressively recreated in
this musical level by Momo Super Mario
maker 2 is filled with these music
levels where the course essentially runs
itself and uses the items and enemies to
make music must have taken a very long
time to get all the pieces to move
perfectly I won't spoil the fun here as
you should definitely try the course for
yourself
[Music]
Zelda tooth The Adventure of Link may be
considered one of the weaker entries in
the series but this recreation of palace
1 in Super Mario maker to buy Turtle
Rock is extremely fun to play little
touches like dots being replaced by
goombahs and stalfos being replaced by
dry bones add that attention to detail
that really brings this whole thing
together if you're familiar was l22 then
you might already know how to beat this
course but it's still worth a shot just
to experience it in a whole new way
[Music]
listen the deco tree recreation for
ocarina of time by majora takes what was
once in 3d and makes it work really well
in 2d a lot of the same puzzles make a
comeback from the original like having
to jump across a falling platform to get
to the other side having to fall through
the holes in the ground and having hit
switches in the same deku order you're
even treated to a re-imagined Goma fight
at the end
last but not least majora also mated to
dongho's cavern recreation from ocarina
of time this course has a lot of puzzles
based around bombs and bombs aren't as
easy to handle here as they were in
ocarina of time it does create some
unique challenges my favorite
reimagining is throwing the bombs and
the eyes of the giant skull only this
time is to get the key parts there's
another boss fight at the end just like
the last one and given the tools
available in Super Mario maker - I
thought they did an exceptional job
reinventing the king dodongo battle
those are seven Legend of Zelda inspired
levels that stood out to us and Super
Mario maker - got any Zelda inspired
courses of your own or ideas for Zelda
levels leave them in the comments below
we'd love to see them
[Music]